ils s'engouffre dans leur véhicule
blindés la suite aurait pu mal tourner
selon leur porte-parole des paparazzis
très agressifs les auraient poursuivis
pendant près de deux heures multiples
collisions éviter de justesse voiture
roulant sur le trottoir manquant de
renversé piétons et policiers portraits
comme celui-ci il y en a une dizaine
placardée sur les abribus ou encore sur
les panneaux afficheurs de Chanel ici
dans le centre-ville d'Avignon tout à
coup il est pas paradis ont encerclé le
taxi avec des flashs il prenait des
photos se mettaient en travers de notre
route et vous vous sentir en danger
non pas vraiment mais vous savez Harry
et Meghan avaient l'air vraiment stressé
Emmanuel Macron y est représenté
caricaturé en Adolf Hitler avec une
moustache 49-3 entourée de ces deux mots
non merci je ne pense pas qu'il y ait
beaucoup d'entre nous qui ne se
souviennent pas de la mort de sa mère et
il serait horrible de perdre un
spectateur innocent au cours d'une telle
course poursuite et qui leur arrive
quelque chose à eux aussi nous devons
être extrêmement responsable quand on
pense là aussi entre guillemets
symboliquement les effigies la première
ministre du président dans les
manifestations pour ça vous demandez à
la France insoumise notamment de la
France notamment pas que mais la France
insoumise a installé dans l'hémicycle un
climat de grande violence Jean-Luc
Mélenchon il sait ce que ça veut dire un
mot le chocolatier de
ça respire le mépris de classe pardon
c'est exactement ça et quand ça sommet
sommet ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire si
on lui avait pas posé la question il
aurait rien dit au fond qu'est-ce que
c'est c'est une espèce de c'est une
folie à la Trump à gauche c'est le Trump
de gauche Jean-Baptiste trogneux lui a
été agressé en raison de son lien avec
le président de la République le petit
neveu de Brigitte Macron a été roué de
coup lundi soir à Amiens et quand
j'entends que non ils ont simplement
bougé des poubelles faut arrêter c'est
des gens qui étaient quand même
déterminés à
aboyer quelqu'un de la famille Macron
quoi le jeune couple en pleine promenade
reçoit des insultes à caractère raciste
par deux adolescents le français de
merde sale blanc le couple est ensuite
agressé physiquement mais les échanges
de coup tourne vite à l'avantage de la
victime qui pratique un sport de combat
depuis ce matin on a essayé de me
convaincre de rester mais non c'est
décide d'aller chercher du renfort
passant de 2 à 10 adolescents prêts en
découdre où est de coup au sol la
victime est arrêtée pour 7 jours sa
compagne dispose de trois jours
d'interruption de travail en France
c'est une mesure supplémentaire pour
prévenir le risque d'incendie il sera
désormais formellement interdit de fumer
à proximité des forêts si le risque est
élevé la mesure vient d'être adoptée par
les députés et attention auxquelles
non-respect il y aura des contrôles je
fais cette vidéo pour dire que j'ai
signé la pétition lancée par la Praille
des banlieu de la PMA pour tous j'ai
signé cette pétition parce que
aujourd'hui la PMA reste excluante mais
il génère aussi un sentiment de zénitude
on le regarde et on n'a pas envie de
d'être ailleurs mais pourquoi je ne sais
pas en fait aujourd'hui les donneurses
et les receveurs doivent correspondre en
termes de couleurs de peau et de couleur
d'eux bon bah déjà ça ça donne mieux à
un traitement administratif absolument
raciste mais également qu'est-ce que ça
veut dire Brigitte Macron a dit adieu à
son panda la première dame et la
marraine du premier panda né en France
en 2017 installé au zoo de Beauval il
doit s'envoler pour la Chine retrouver
sa famille au mois de juillet ça veut
dire que dans les faits aujourd'hui les
personnes non blanches les personnes
racisées
ont des délais d'attente pour bénéficier
de la PMA qui sont deux trois fois plus
longs que celles des personnes blanches
pour la première fois un double
numérique de l'épave donne une vue
globale du géant des mers
111 ans après son naufrage
le stade olympique de Londres ne
pourrait accueillir qu'une partie
seulement de l'épave qui s'est cassée en
deux en son brand cette technologie 3D
devrait permettre aux scientifiques de
mieux comprendre les circonstances de
l'accident et peut-être d'avoir de
nouvelles réponses sans 11 ans plus tard